Japan is facing one of the largest
population collapses in modern history
by the Year 2060 Japan's population is
expected to drop by a third to about 80
million people the country is trying to
tackle the crisis by introducing
lifelike robots to help with daily life
a new CBS News primetime series series
CBS n on assignment looks at the
humanoids Adam Yamaguchi traveled to the
University of Osaka he learns why
Japan's culture is uniquely suited to
accept the machines I can see your
breathing your shoulders sort of going
in and out do you ever find yourself
working in here and you freak out
because you turn away you look away
never you don't get started with come on
the goal here is to make the robots as
realistic as possible to test how humans
react and respond to humanoids she feels
very realistic is my response
typical No people won't touch it people
will ask for permission before it touch
her
my parents didn't teach me any manners
is the problem that's all hi these
robots are the creation of dr. Hiroshi
Ishiguro known as The Godfather of
humanoids oh how many robots do you have
it here and one of his most famous
creations is himself a humanoid form the
people complete I think I know the my
motivation is is to build a robot but it
is not true so my motivation is to
understand what human is by developing a
human
fifty years the Japanese population
going to be a half half of our current
population better still of course you
know that we want to keep the exam level
of our quality of life so the how we can
do that answer is to develop robot that
can support our daily life
Adam Yamaguchi is with us now Adam good
morning morning so how are the Japanese
looking to integrate these robots in
every way yeah I mean in simple terms
what they envision is essentially
Westworld
they want to find a society or create a
society that show on HBO HBO they want
to create a society in which robots
humanoids and humans live and coexist
side by side and and the lines between
those two are blurred so you'll see
you'll see them you already see them in
restaurants and shopping malls
you'll start to see them working as as
news anchors as teachers I was talking
talking
it was a little creepy because they were
so lifelike to me the blinking is what
got me and the turning of the head what
was it like for you who touched them
without asking I would say the only
difference between the the robots and a
real-life human was was that her skin
was much colder that was the only thing
but you know when I sat down and
interviewed Erica the robot momentarily
I would forget that she was not in fact
a human she looks at you she blinks she
nods she acknowledges that you're there
and and you forget and and that's the
whole idea the robot assist that we
talked to it said the moment you start
to forget that this is not in fact a
human is when we've succeeded and what's
happening in Japan is gonna happen here
and everywhere else
absolutely around the world thank you
looks like a great piece yeah thank you
and you can watch Adams full report on
the premiere episode of CBS n on
assignment at airs Monday night at 10:00
9:00 central here on CBS and our
streaming network cbsn